hi welcome back to another gadget lab
show I am Michael colori now I'm Nathan
Oh Devadas Giles and Nathan what is that
you have in your hands this is the
samsung galaxy s3 and it is the latest
and greatest from Samsung it's available
on AT&T Sprint t-mobile Verizon US
cellular I'm actually really excited
about that one phone for all those
carriers since it's like the hot android
phone of summer right ah this is one of
the hot android phones the summer i
still prefer the HTC One X I still think
that's the best overall android phone
out there at this moment the galaxy
nexus still has a you know really dear
place in my heart but this is a
fantastic phone top top top line specs
dual-core processor 2 gigs of ram it
costs 200 bucks on to your contract so
yeah pretty solid you know on paper yeah
but after using it for a few days you
had noticed in your review you mentioned
some problems in software yeah well it's
fast it's and it's great and it's a good
phone but there are some software quarks
there's a bunch of sharing features
sharing photos between phones a lot of
things that use near field
communications but none of those
features were too easy to use and
there's like five different ways to
share a photo I go over all that stuff
in my review which is actually live now
at wired.com / reviews but it's there's
a lot I mean there's just it almost
feels like there's too many ideas in
this phone for what this phone is
actually pulling off right now okay so
the thing that I know we want to talk
about is the S voice right this is the
Serie competitor yes so the iphone
brought a Serie you can talk to your
phone you know schedule appointments
check the weather Samsung's doing that
with the feature called s voice and you
know there's a lot of folks who don't
love Siri don't think that it works well
enough s boys I couldn't get it working
for about four days straight at all and
finally I can get it to kind of work now
but it doesn't work very well okay now
I've noticed that like a lot of the
reviews said the same thing about it
which is that it only works about half
the time and it doesn't quite understand
it and then it just feels half babes and
you said the same thing in your review
even though when you could
get it to work all you could really get
to do is respond to you saying hello
yeah yeah the most i could get it to say
was you know hello nice to meet you and
just today i actually got it to tell me
what the weather was or got my
appointments for my calendar nice I even
got it to tell me how it's all about
Whitney is so what do you think kind of
gimmicky kind of cool where does it fall
on the gimmicky cool spectrum um right
now it's a cool gimmick is that a cop
out I don't know you this is not going
to change the way that you use your
phone it's not going to replace actually
going and navigating and you know just
actually using the phone as you have
them before this is cutting-edge
technology it's really at the most
infant stage right now and Samsung
doesn't have even close to what series
doing right now but they got a lot of
money they've got a lot of resources
hopefully they'll figure it out but and
it is in this where the industry is
going because you know with the launch
of Siri and s voice and now LG is
announced its going to have its own
competing voice recognition voice
command system so yeah I'm sure more to
come and it's probably just going to get
better yeah I actually got a statement
from Samsung saying that they're working
on it okay yeah they're going to be
constantly proving yeah there's no
that's my shoes yeah I'd really like to
see Google get out ahead of this and
come up with their own version this way
we don't have 15 different boys
competitors you know yeah well we will
before that happens I'm sure probably
well we have to move on so thanks for
bringing the phone again as Nathan said
you could read his whole review wire.com
reviews and up next alexander is
going to join us and she's going to tell
us about some
alexander's here yes hello uh you
attended to Microsoft mobile events this
week yes I did and the first one was for
the microsoft surface which was a really
big secret up until the event and they
basically had his flying down to LA and
they didn't tell us where the location
was until the day of and then lo and
behold at three-thirty p.m. they
revealed this tablet a Microsoft branded
tablet called the microsoft surface and
a lot on I got very limited hands-on
time with it about minutes and let's say
under around 2 minutes around 2 minutes
so what are your impressions on it now
also we should make clear they were to
write write this is one of the consumer
one there's one that's going around on
Windows RT which is the consumer one and
one for windows 8 pro which is the
business one which one did you get I saw
when does the windows RT one which is
for consumers and basically the sort of
marquee features of the surface are that
at the kickstand and it's a pretty nice
kickstand Microsoft is pretty obsessed
with it and then it has a cover a touch
cover and what's so great about the
touch cover is that it has a built-in
keyboard and trackpad very cool now did
you get to try the keyboard I got to put
my hands on the keyboard and it was the
touch cover so it was a flat like
pressure sensitive touch cover but they
didn't actually let us type on it we're
thinking that it just might not be
finished okay well I suppose we'll have
more on that one or on right and it's
it'll be coming in the fall when windows
8 launches okay so probably like
octoberish sure September's I'm thinking
October okay and the other thing you saw
this week was the windows 8 windows
phone 8 sorry when does follow me so
that was at the Windows Phone summit
yesterday so it's a really microsoft
packed week and basically they
officially unveiled Windows Phone 8 and
there were a lot of rumors going around
about Linda's phone 8 and basically
microsoft confirmed a lot of those it's
gotten a lot of hardware updates
support dual core well multi-core chips
and right now windows windows phones
have been stuck with a single corner
right not really hardware so now they'll
be actually be able to compete a little
bit more in the mobile space and they'll
also have NFC micro SD slots new screen
resolutions they'll support like higher
resolution screens and this mobile
wallet thing which is sort of becoming
really popular that's a payment system
like it Kevin Hagen right just have to
pay and then also kind of like the whole
passbook apple passbook you can store
all of your deals and third-party
services directly in one app so it looks
like Windows Phone 8 is going to be the
thing that's going to allow Windows
Phones to be market competitive you know
feature for feature with all the other
popular anything yeah and it's basically
building out the whole windows ecosystem
because it'll be like shared core with
windows 8 and windows phone 8 that's
awesome that's not news and what is that
around also the fall it's going to be a
big fall for Microsoft okay well I
supposed to be completed for a company
in here yeah maybe I won't even be
called Microsoft and it'll just be
called phone service surface smart glass
company all right well anyway enough
speculation about what their name change
is going to be but we're going to go to
Robbie who is going to show us some cool
stuff for the inside of car
so now Robbie see your hi Robbie hey
you've got some pretty cool gadgets for
living in your van well you don't have
to live in your van oh well part time
like you may just like your summer home
so I got some gadgets some things you
can plug into your car and one of them
is actually it's like a slow cooker it's
made by Burton you plug in your dog
don't worry company not the snowboarding
get nothing to do with the snowboarding
company but this you can can make like a
like a stew in here and then this
steamer you could space and vegetable
aisle like asparagus yeah so in your van
smell wonderful yeah your make your van
or your call your Lincoln Town Car you
know maybe maybe you're sick of the red
side burgers and you want you know oh my
god has this great recipe for goulash
that is super cool boom you can put it
in there it's a it's going to take you
two hours to cook anything though so you
can't just do this on your commute to
work I think this is sort of thing
that's going to appeal to people who are
forgers yes you know people who like to
go out like mushroom hunting and maybe
steal a couple of carrots from the
garden yeah yeah so if you're a thief on
the go that's your slow cooker that's
your slow cooker what else have you got
what's that other than others i also got
an electric blanket that we plug into
your car it's the car cozy too so it's
like it's like a Snuggie or like a sonic
it so you can form like a bigger it's
like a week as well if you like it
underneath it when I would plug in and
has a half hour and 45 minutes timer
don't hit your mind and yours like this
is especially helpful if you have
someone in the car possibly the driver
who gets hot blooded and it's really
warm like my wife would probably love
this because if they're up to me that
air conditioning be on like 50 degrees
yeah yeah kimchi wake while you drive
yeah yeah so she could like I'm just
assuming that you're driving yeah all
right sorry so one of the things that I
noticed about about your your whole
gallery which of course you can view in
all of its glory on Gadget Lab the
gadget lab is that a lot of these
products like they all plug into the
cigarette lighter but they have
different voltage requirements and
is that a concern for most people I
think that the most part ii should be ok
most new cars if you have an older car
there you know there's always yeah if
you're having a 78 near mercury if
there's more than you know the voltage
of your car is probably the least of
your concerns but you know you should
check your owners manual to see how much
voltage is being put out and also when
you before you buy these things you know
a lot of people have vans and suvs and
78 Mercury's and something that you just
managed to alienate all of them sorry
more people with mercury just go running
well you know what we love you we want
you to come back next week because
that's all we have for this week and
we'll be back with some hopefully some
updates from the google i/o conference
which is taking place here in san
francisco last week and you so until
then we'll see